hi
the birthday to Jude and realize I
confuse myself and saw today is the
anniversary it was this day one year ago
where we sat here my chin was a lot
bigger back then we glitched our way
through our first show how do you feel
like you have changed
well my outfit is just so much better
today than it was a year ago you know
you truly like I didn't know you were
going to the prom and I was with Toby
you said toasty you said toasty like so
I wore pink I said toasty I might if I
had known I needed my prom dress I would
have worn it I said toasty I'm wearing
poms wear something with palms
he said toasty like I wore pink like I
just thought it was a regular day no it
looks good I mean I look like I am your
counselor I'm the chaperone of the prom
that's what I look like between my hair
miss ungermeyer and i'm wearing the hat
for many reasons one because we are
launching merch today so it's at the end
of the show all the merch will go live
we are doing our best sellers with a
couple of new products so if you weren't
able to get something in a previous
launch you'll be able to get it now and
I'm wearing a hat because this is the
first time since my kind of dramatic
haircut that I didn't like blow it out
or anything I've just been really hard
on my hair and I want you're having a
bad hair day I know and I'm feeling I'm
not having a bad hair day yet I'm just
feeling a really self-conscious I'm
gonna show it to you I want to take the
hat off well the good news is I didn't
notice okay ready
close your eyes cuz I have to figure it
it's not that shocking okay if you look
the same no it's just I've been flat
ironing it every day cuz I went a little
shorter than intended so until it curves
back I'm just like flat ironing and
stuff it's just like I don't know it's
feeling like a little puppy and it's not
great it looks the same as always also
exciting about the merger so it'll be
available on limited quantity 24 hours
as always it'll go live at the end of
the show as always so as we always say
but since there is some confusion it
won't sell out so you have an entire day
to get but because we're doing it that
way that means it will get you two
winners it's made to order because if we
can't preorder because then there'll be
limited stock if everyone wants to get
as much as they can that means that
there will be a two-week waiting period
till you get your merch and it goes by
very fast and the exciting thing about
today's merch opening is that when you
spend $50 on your order you get a free
morning toast champagne stemless flute
which is what we posted on our Instagram
you can also just buy a regular if you
don't want to spend $50 but if you find
yourself just spending $50 you get the
free flute yeah it's exciting so
our gift to you for being with oil
toasters ride what a ride it has been
how do you feel since a year ago
emotionally what have you learned
honestly I feel very just like confident
and sure it's like if you'd asked me a
year ago where do I want to be in a year
I would have said right here like and
that's what we have always said it's not
like any year I want to be queen of the
world right like in a year I want to
work hard I want to plant my seeds and I
want them to bear fruit you know makes
me excited but you're talking like Game
of Thrones because I go let my whole
brain is me teary-eyed be both been
catching up on Game of Thrones just like
we watching trying to learn before the
new season and in bed last night I was
like to bed and I was like you on the
right foot like I've just been talking
so weird cuz when you like I've been
talking to anyone I've been watching
Game of Thrones for three days straight
and now I live in concluding cool so of
this what I would say so like if you
think back a year ago where we are now
like so much has happened it makes me
excited for next year like next year
this time where are we gonna be and then
that someone's gonna find this clip of
me saying it and like look Claudia said
it and now she's got a Netflix special
you know right and it's just goes to
show hard work and dedication there's
really there's no other formula truly
hard work dedication and patience you
know hard work dedication patience and
seen vibes oh of course
because you know what that's the
x-factor that's the secret sauce is the
senior vibe right keep the show what it
is and it keeps the community it's a
good burger the the movie secrecy buds
but so you know what else it is it's
like work hard play hard you know I feel
like I go non-stop like working and then
I just party like my face off and that's
how I got strep I think sorry I by the
way I did to me treats this weekend like
i 100% gave the entire flips state of
florida strap I'm sure I give invited I
gave them morning but I feel like having
strep and far does not as Beck saying
you go in the Sun and the Sun cures all
well you know what's so crazy is I mean
it kind of metastasizing the disease I
left New York on Friday night like strep
like I knew I had strep when I landed in
Florida on Saturday I was just miserable
I texted my uncle who's a florida doctor
in florida he gave me a mom sicilian
like i knew i had strep and I was
feeling so much better and then I got
back to New York and I feel horrible
it's something about like the air here I
think let's see look
lissa T whenever you're ready to go I'm
my bad
cerpac really cuz I've you know I've
been on this journey the dirty jeans
store
we're heading to Greenville in
Greensboro North Carolina South Carolina
next weekend when I get tickets
available at girl no job calm and it
kind of just been scouting out cities
for us you know doing the work you
thought you really wanted to move to
Cleveland and I was here to tell you
that I don't think Cleveland is the
place for you I've seen the world you
know and I'm still I'm still going but I
think really Charlotte is the place for
you yeah that's what you said or maybe
somewhere warmer like like a Dallas
which would make a lot of sense for you
yeah it's yeah the here the highs and
lows I mean the thing is I would go
personally I would move anywhere like
any state sounds appealing to me as long
as they don't have any contacts but it's
like it has to be somewhere where you
guys want to go right design all in on
Charlotte Charlotte is good in New York
but Dallas doesn't have any context and
neither does Nashville oh but Charlotte
does I figured that reason I'm out for
that reason yeah as well so um they also
don't have an income tax in Florida but
I just think I could handle the chub-rub
that ensues in a warm sunny state like
that you couldn't move to fire yeah no
I'm thinking really like Nashville's a
place for me and you know I have a long
career ahead of me in music and I just
think that's where I should be exciting
and every time I go to Nashville I look
up apartments for rent for the same
amount of money that I'm paying in New
York and like I could be a king in in
Nashville we we could be Kings anywhere
but here yeah your work the sorry people
yeah I love that clip she thinks she's
the queen and we're so she should have
been cast in Game of Thrones as like REI
strong great know as arias little Oh
totally awesome or as arias like chubby
friend that she meets on the way to
King's Landing
ah hot pie yeah no he's great the way
that he is
we'll talk Game of Thrones we'll also
talk about if I'm Brooks because I
watched this morning i watch last night
my new thing it's like watching shows as
I get ready for the toast because it's
more fresh in my mind
the amnesia it's like if I watched and
remember last night I wouldn't be able
to remember the most horrible moment
where Sheena was crying that Lalla
didn't want to make out with her and now
that I watched it this morning I can
remember that for me the most horrible
moment was one when they were planning
for the potty
Oh Harley realizing I made the joke last
week on the Tosun like okay I had the
same sense of humor it's [ __ ] like oh
okay I just said I can let me just head
potty potty right like so I'm like when
basically like that scene was just so
sad like how can we film what's gonna be
interesting yeah that's it Bert and
that's the best idea that they came up
with and they basically went to her and
asked everyone hi Stassi will you film
with me no truly
Jax will you guys film with us hey no we
must increase my longevity on the show
no will you guys contribute to my
renewal next season no I'm sorry she
she's in the opening scene did she get
paid she definitely gets paid but not a
kept like a cast no no no I wouldn't
consider her like top but she definitely
got something a couple hundred bucks
okay you know her for the dogs for the
potty for the party
okay so what we're gonna do - what are
we gonna do you're gonna do a regular
show and just throughout we'll just take
time to reflect on the past year as
things come up then towards the end well
you know do a little reminiscing there
like a little Q&A okay um and yeah and
just commemorate this special day in
toast history oh and then before we do
that we have a very interesting schedule
this week today it's me and Jackie
tomorrow it's me and Jackie and then
Blake horseman which like I'm not
excited to talk to him because I have
one burning question inside myself for
him and it is why is your Instagram
balakay I just don't understand that I
want to know then on Thursday we have
icon queen role model and inspiration to
young women everywhere
a woman who supports other woman women
Ramona Singer is gonna be here she's
gonna be promoting her new skincare line
to just grab it's ageless bye Ramona I
actually got a tube and it is so well
done like classy as [ __ ] she must have
some QVC money in there because it looks
like really like sitting uh Cindy
Crawford shows those commercials in the
middle that night
that's what Ramona is doing and she's
gonna make some real money from a nice
yes so I have it and it's pretty good
[ __ ] so ang over here talking about that
Thursday we embark to the desert after
40 years the Gees are going back to the
desert to Coachella no show Friday but
we will be serving up the premium cotton
Jews are going back to the desert but
we've learned our lesson yeah we went to
Coachella two years ago and we vowed to
never return again but unfortunately
that's just not the way the world works
and there are opportunities for us at
Coachella and we have to go but we have
learned here's what I've learned I have
bought now an external charger and a
Mophie charging case for my phone
because roaming we also have special
parking passes because that is just the
only way to live yeah we have portable
fans I got some did you get any no no I
don't my purse is armed thinking after
all this I got a special stick I forget
what it's called for my chub rub it's
called
mega babe yes they sell at Sephora and
it's fantastic so I'm just like stockist
I feel like I'm actually going to war
and I'm stocking up on like steel and
food for my family canned goods oh my
gosh Ella is [ __ ] Westeros yes no
truly so if you have been to Coachella
and you find that there are resources
that you use please let me know so I can
order on Amazon have it sent to the
hotel let me get you know JAL we will
have 35,000 boxes there because I'm just
sending all my stuff there I also didn't
like get enough clothing in time so I'm
like spending all my kimonos and like
rompers
to Coachella that's always a great idea
yeah it's also it never makes a
desperate IDI oh and even though like
usually the last time we went to
Coachella we decided two days before so
we had to send all of our ASA owners to
our hotel but we've now know for like
three weeks that we were going to
Coachella and I tried to the point right
it's not like you just like didn't do it
it didn't work out so now you're didn't
work out I did revolve I did eight shows
ASOS has actually stepped up their game
for a while they were like really just
lowbrow and like not cutting it for me I
also like need to stop ordering clothes
when I'm feeling down and myself because
I order clothes that like don't fit me
yeah what I mean yeah and they don't
really know my size anymore because okay
in like a real store we're like the
sizing is like for real women I'm a
certain size but then I'm like ASOS or
revolve we're like you know material is
at a limit like I feel like ASIS is
really size inclusive like they have
size inclusive but I mean like in terms
of sizing like ASOS it's so cheap that
like you're like three sizes up because
they don't have much material to spare
for there's cheap prices whereas they
gonna real store like Bloomingdale's
you're an actual size you know I think
it's the opposite no oh my god really
yeah in Bloomingdale's like I'm truly
like a size I wouldn't say a so said
Merv Albar the same thing like I would
say we're evolved this is like its own I
was if you're comparing a snow source
moon is I feel like a chose has so many
more sizes and varieties like you can
get your actual size at ASOS not up to
me okay no so II know it's like they're
in orbit items on the wrap-up right they
have a zero they have a six and then
they have an eight you know you're right
about that
about like options but in actual terms
of like sizing like Bloomingdale's
Bloomingdale's sizing is like real
fashion sizing I feel like and then
actually I don't know whatever all I
know is that like I can't like at
Bloomingdale's zero the two and the four
are the same maybe but at Bloomingdale's
like I could fit into like an eight
whereas like on ASOS like I have some
by myself or wearing a 16 like literally
double but it doesn't fit do you know
what I mean I'm just going through like
honestly body dysmorphia these days and
I don't know what I look like and I
can't like I said I was I'm feeling
really down in myself and I ordered like
huge clothing and it comes I'm like why
don't order this then times him
sometimes I feel like I'm actually Kate
Upton I don't order it I literally got a
dress and I'm like I did not order this
like there's literally no way in my mind
I would ever think that this would look
good on me or and it's in this size it's
crazy how like your mind plays tricks on
you you know yeah that's funny
well without further ado I believe for
the how many episodes have we done like
215 I don't know
for the 207 anything tribe today like
what how many episodes should we have
done I can tell you two weeks in New
Year five days a week I'm good we I can
tell you because pretty much we upload
everything to podcast so the podcast app
actually counts it for you yeah so this
is our we had two seasons yeah I got you
I got you bro I got you
it is all episodes this is our 213 that
said Wow yeah that's crazy I know and
it's crazy how like shows TV shows when
they hit a hundred episodes it's like
everyone shits their play-doh get a cape
they get a raise and a sag and 213 and
you don't hear no raise just say Jesus
congratulatory actually we're throwing
we threw ourselves a party that's true
that was for a year though yeah yeah
yeah please please he was a soirée calm
down everyone Jackie did a great job of
planning the soiree it was very very
refined it was very tasteful very it was
like it was us what a party for a
morning show and have a third caliber I
I was very doubtful Jackie and I was
skeptical of the budget you were but did
you have to say you spread that money
real thin girl and you did it
thank you thanks to our seventeen wasn't
beautiful so today really very much it
was an in hindsight such three vibes
with the fireplaces it also know they
think about it put some balloon ordering
it never came oops they're probably in
the sky they set them free oh my god
that's so weird
Nico ish okay whatever okay you do not
really should balloon to the sky they
kill dolphins or something like that
no they end up in ocean and
I'll strangle Turtles yeah okay first
story Felicity Huffman in 12 others to
plead guilty in college admissions skin
but not Lori Loughlin right not ok so I
guess Felicity will take will be the
face of the business of those who pled
guilty of glory will be the face of
those who are pleading innocent or no
Lori's like the face of those who spent
under fifty grand
yeah I mean Felicity's the the face of
people who spent under fifty grand
yeah but it's like even still or I know
she spent half million dollars Hillary
Lachlan but think it was a quarter
million per kid compared to others who
paid six million so it's like
technically Lori lock-ins on the low end
right but not in the comparative
Felicity Huffman right it's just they're
the most famous so you're comparing Lori
to Felicity right when in actuality
there are people who did by the way like
no college education is worth six
million dollars honestly no college
education is even worth 15 grand and if
you have six million dollars just to
throw around then your kid really
doesn't need to go to college yeah but
it's a six million person I don't know
what I'm just like wealthy people who we
don't know who we need to become foreign
semester they can give us six million
dollars so we can visit them in jail
yeah totally
actress Felicity Hoffman will plead
guilty over her role in nationwide
college admissions scandal along with a
dozen other Bobby's hair that's five
sorry oh my god I don't have any
episodes oh yeah okay ready let's do
together without further ado here are
the fascinate with that's right these or
here oh I see here what do you say ten
times pound feelin okay so you see
without further ado then we'll stop
right into here okay without further ado
here are the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
Felicity happen to twelve others to
plead guilty and College Admission
scandal so Desperate Housewives star
will join 12 other disgraced moms and
dads in copping to conspiracy to commit
mail fraud and honest services mail
fraud for paying bribes to ease their
privilege progenies admission into top
schools by either fudging the kids exam
scores are getting coaches to name them
as bogus athletic recruits they all face
up to 20 years behind bars a felicity
made a statement uh she said I'm ashamed
of the pain I've caused my daughter my
family my friends my colleagues and the
educational community I want to
apologize to them
I want to apologize to the students who
work hard every day to get into college
and to their parents who make tremendous
sacrifices to support their children and
do so honestly my daughter knew
absolutely nothing about my actions and
in my misguided her family wrong way I
have betrayed her this transgression
toward her in the public I will carry
for the rest of my life my desire to
help my daughter is no excuse to break
the law or engage in dishonesty that is
a good statement she's working with a
fine publicist like like a like a 20k
retainer publicist you know what I'm
saying mm-hmm
yeah these crisis management regardless
it's like they just [ __ ] cash in on
people's misfortune whether or not the
daughter knew like good on her to fall
on the sword yet no totally I feel like
so she's not going to know she like
we're waiting sentencing but she pled
guilty she pled guilty along with a
bunch of other people usually when you
plead guilty like you make a deal with
the judge maybe they'll gave up other
information maybe they know of another
crime going on that's how this case
actually can break the forefront someone
got like securities dated and then they
were like go easy on me I'll give you a
bigger fish yeah I got more laughlin
right I got I'm gonna take down the
college admissions process well this is
a nice statement and honestly it feels
sort of genuine I just love that they
still refer to her as the Desperate
Housewives star I mean no but she's in
that show American crime no she's in
watch oh yeah right no but it's like a
big show that everyone loves I think
would you know it's it's also on ABC
it's called American crime I feel like
that's what it's called but it's eerily
similar to American crime story I'm
gonna say it's American crime for sure
okay I'll take I'll take American crime
for 200 Alex okay so now I go under I
don't think they'll go to jail that
would seem very harsh these people these
people I don't think I'll go to jail I
mean I mean either I don't know but then
it's like why wouldn't everyone plead
guilty if they just man like right I
just not on there I mean someone who
doesn't plead guilty is a [ __ ] like
there's an insurmountable amount of
evidence but they might be able to prove
like that they know right what what the
the guy was gonna do for them or that it
was illegal got it got it
well the Felicity Huffman is out here
doing the right thing
how many other people pleaded guilty 12
others so does that mean Lori Loughlin
is not gonna plead guilty or she's just
in a different like group um as of right
now she's not pleading guilty I guess
because the senior said they're already
charged together yeah I did I thought
she loved herself fine like there's no
right way to handle walking into court
and if she subs her fans who showed up
for her with pictures of Aunt Becky like
then the only people who still support
her are gonna turn on her that's so true
you know I wonder what like the Olivia
Jade stamps are thinking right now
because I was actually trying to like
look at some of her fan accounts I don't
remember they go in private so there's
one I just want a probably should take
the heat because the Internet is
disgusting right and they're just like
teenage girls who like love this like
pretty rich girl I think that they are
ready to forgive her and accept her but
the problem is that she can't apologize
and make a statement because this is
like a legal case you can't speak on it
and people can't forgive you if you
don't have the opportunity to apologize
right so she her hands are tied
also when like a youtuber or like
someone goes through like a cancellation
they always come back because this is
their livelihood like I don't I feel
like Olivia Jade might never come back
to YouTube she doesn't need to be a
youtuber she did it for fun as a hobby
and then it turned into a career okay at
this point she kind of needs me youtuber
because she's not going to college
great parents won't work again but honey
okay but you want to just like live off
this pot for the rest like you need
income still yeah well she's still
getting those full house for lt''s Becky
which is definitely a lot because they
play syndicated on like ABC Family would
be fine if none of them ever worked
again I think I don't know their
finances but I don't think they would
live at the level that they live now
because right now they live like you
know you spent you earned money you
spend money right they would have they
wouldn't be earning to downsize you they
would definitely have to downsize and I
think Olivia Jade could and very well
should go back to be an influencer when
she can yeah because I think but you
can't for a very long time because this
thing is like never gonna end
he's it's a court thing but it's a
current her subscribers are still there
last time I checked she has more
followers now than she did before this
ever happened a lot of controversy me as
one of them because ever since this
started I like then I went to check out
her stuff because I saw she was making
videos from college I was like how
hilarious yeah the irony and then I saw
this [ __ ] in her dorm room like
her laundry and I was like this is
really cute I mean I've been trying to
tell you about Olivia Jade forever me
and Margot are obsessed with her but I
you guys like loved her makeup tutorials
and I'm sorry I can't like I don't care
about her makeup because it's like
everyone has great skin when they're 18
years we're not watching for the
technique we're just watching cuz she's
like so pretty and I want to see what
her house and like if her mom pops her
head it you know okay well no you were
watching better there was a while when
you weren't wearing foundation because
yeah because love AJ told me to you're
losing concealer I found a you know I
got all the Klimt because I thought I
was like 18 year old perfect skinny
influencer right but I did think was
interesting like being an influencer in
college like she took us around the dorm
she cleaned her little room she got
ready for her frat party she was so
excited I mean it's like also she's
gotten too cool Hollywood parties but no
matter how cool you are in Hollywood
like a frat parties a frat party and
that hierarchy exists you are - rushman
especially at USC like no matter how
cool you are no matter how famous you
are like rushing the sororities like the
sorority like world it's tough like
girls are so mean but a USC it's
heightened to like another level where
every girl is just blonde and perfect
and like has a rich father so like right
so she's sure we comply perfect I like
didn't make her so it was interesting to
watch this girl who had a perfect life
like actually like have to make friends
like no matter how cool you are like
making friends in college is still
awkward and weird right so I found it
full of interesting factoids that we're
interesting and I subscribe and I
followed her because of it
I can't imagine I'm the only one who
didn't know her work before checks her
out oh this girl's getting so much buzz
she's the face of this major NAT
nationwide scandal what's she all about
right what's it all about so I think
she'll have to take the time I mean if
her mom Club guilty she can maybe like
that would speed things along so it'll
take longer now but I would be
disappointed in her if she didn't come
back if she didn't at least try yeah but
you know what it's a very brave thing to
do and not everyone can do it no I know
it's really it shows like what you're
made up it's not about what how you fall
and get knocked down it's how you get
back up I mean and on the one-year
anniversary of the toes yeah I'm telling
you Olivia Jade it's gonna do it you can
do it but at the same time leave in
yourself when when this is your job and
it's your livelihood you have more of a
motivating force behind you to get back
up even though people can like tear you
down and like make fun of your set but
but when you're what born with like a
silver spoon in your mouth and you
really you were never doing YouTube or
whatever as like a means to pay your
rent and you never know when it's like
like maybe not have an income it's less
motivating for you to get back up you'll
just get up and just live your life
that's like another socialite perhaps
you know but she's but she can't even do
that anymore right
and yeah but people love a good scandal
so like I feel like we're in the thick
of it right now so we can't see out of
it and that's how it happens with the
scandal but like in three years we'll be
like oh that college scandal thing and
it will have been like prestigious to be
a part of it cuz that's how [ __ ] up
our world is right it's like anyone who
was involved in the OJ Simpson case
Kardashian's right your Marshall Clark
is out here like producing television
shows right on both sides
everyone who touched the agenda that
case benefited right but they all had
books like America loves a scandal so
right now it's like in the thick of it
what you did is that but in five years
like it'll just be a part of her
discography and she will have been like
a part of this collaborative field money
filled scandal but it's what she does
between now and in five years from now
that will set her up for the rest of her
life agreed agreed agreed
so also like what's going on with
Felicity Huffman skids it's crazy that
we still don't know who they are right
and also where did they even go to
school it's like they pay fifteen
thousand dollars because they went to
like some arts place yeah not not not
that prestigious but they're thinking
they're stars every day that Olivia Jade
started a YouTube channel three years
ago hey nobody has even me I didn't even
seen a picture of them there's one
picture of them going around from like
the Golden Globes of them with both of
their parents and that's it I think it's
the only time they ever let stepped out
of their house with their parents and
they're so [ __ ] grateful like
literally on their knees every night
thinking out that Olivia Jade was born
yeah because she has really taken like
the full brunt of this scandal totally
speaking of scandals this one's an even
bigger one and like it's not getting
that much press and I don't want to be
one of these people who contribute to it
not getting press cuz things like this
in Hollywood need to be discussed okay
sobbing Alison Mac pleads guilty insects
cold case people were obsessed with the
signatories crazier than a [ __ ]
college admissions can totally yet if
you watch any show no one talks about
this case I know because Alison Mac like
isn't that favor but it's not just her
know it's in this whole like I mean it
was a cult called nexium and it was a
human a sex trafficking and this is
really going on so long we were talking
about this on the breath mhmmm Wow but
like no one's like picked it back up and
now like things are coming out okay what
happened
Smallville's star aliceandmac gave a
Teen Choice Award word the page six is
being so wow that is shade if I've truly
ever your Teen Choice Award worthy
performance Monday when she pleaded
guilty for her role as the right-hand
woman
in sex slave called nexium sobbing like
a soap star the whole time I almost said
poor sister that to a blubbering Mack
who won the dubious honor of best
sidekick in a TV series for her role on
the CW Superman drama and booze both
2006 and 2007 appeared in Brooklyn
federal court where she copped to
racketeering and racketeering conspiracy
charges including extortion and forced
labor
I'm here to plead guilty before your
honor the actress said before crying so
much that Judge Nicholas guru 'thus
stopped to offer her tissues Oh God
quote I must be full responsibility for
my conduct I'm very sorry for my role in
this case I am very sorry to my family
and to the good people I hurt through my
misguided adherence to nexium leader
Keith Rooney eras teachings not
continued after composing herself she
had been facing such trafficking charges
prosecutors alleged women and EOS were
branded with Rainiers initials and
groomed to have sex with him but they
were not among the counts she pleaded to
Monday however she admitted to keeping a
slave and that she instructed women in
the group to perform to quote perform
services for me
she said the system was designed to make
them think they could suffer serious
harm if they didn't prefer perform the
services because they'd handed over
damaging collateral to do s such as nude
photos and financial details I was a
member of a secret society founded by
Keith raniera Mac told the court I can
see i concealed Keith raniera all as the
head of d OS the craziest part about
this whole thing is the celebrities who
came out afterwards being like yeah this
girl say Mac like tried to text me once
if you were to get me yeah she's like
hey I had this opportunity of you she's
like literally selling like Rodan and
fields lash boost but it's a cult yeah
it so called and it's a dirty disgusting
cold and it runs deep and where's the
guy Keith now did he go to jail yet or
he's still also being tried I'm not sure
because we haven't been keeping up with
the story but you know so crazy it's so
true nobody's talking about like
something that was very much going on in
Hollywood
I mean it's worse than anything else
we've ever talked about a slave yeah
Hollywood no horrible cult worse than
Michael Jackson Morrison r.kelly a great
worse than Harvey Weinstein worse than
the college
mrs. scandal and we don't talk about it
honestly because now I have a pit like
it's it's that time it's really bad and
like you it gets even worse once you see
what the guy Keith looks like I know
that's mean to say well okay no song I
hadn't seen it's like so greasy better
or worse than Harvey Weinstein okay
better but like that's that's not saying
I there are very few people who are
worse looking than Harvey Weinstein
there are eight depends well it depends
at one way and also depends on your type
yeah it shows your true I guess Georgina
Chapman likes his sweaty bald man I
guess like the scandals that that the
world decides to take on and cancel are
so weird do you know II mean huh and
that obviously the world revolves around
Michael Jackson it's like he has
arguably the biggest most horrible like
deep running vile scandal in the world
and literally nobody cares you know I
mean yes like people should camera but
also it's like I don't know if that it's
even the most horrible deep running
Sandlin no totally but it's really bad
especially if you watch a documentary in
here like the real intimate sexual
details of their relationships like it's
really bad no it's literally nobody
cares and if you speak out about it like
you're evil like people came for Oprah
no but also if you see you can't it's
like we can't ever decide I don't know
if we're gonna reach a consensus on that
one well I don't think some of the
details like I guess weren't totally
accurate there was I saw that as well
there was a biographer of Michael
Jackson yeah there was an issue in the
documentary about the years in which the
train station was built for Neverland
and one of the guys was like in when I
was nine and whenever a year we were in
the train station and then the Santa
Barbara like architectural department
has like paperwork that they didn't even
get permits to start building that until
like two years later so there was like a
but that I don't doubt their entire
story cuz he didn't remember one year
sorry in the 18 years of abuse each he
was I don't remember what I was doing
when I was nine no but sorry that you
know James in the 18 years of abuse he
confused you know one rape with another
please it's such [ __ ] anyone I'm
just I'm sorry I'm not here for it and
you know now that we're talking about
cults I have to tell you about my week
up in Clearwater oh right okay you in
Smith okay so do you guys know
Clearwater is the headquarters
of Scientology that's where they have
their Sea Org and if you're just like in
town me and lardo stayed on the beach so
we had to like take a bridge to our
hotel so it was kind of separated but
once we took the bridge and went to the
venue our venue was across the street
from the Sea Org and my dresser had like
a little balcony on it and I'm just like
looking down at clear water and I see
the staff members they dressed like
flight attendants they were like sweater
vests and like little bow ties so I saw
one woman it was honestly so scary like
I ran back in like as if they were gonna
get me and the whole time I was in clear
water I was like so perplexed I'm like
am I gonna joke about it like it's funny
and obviously it's what they're known
for like they know that that's what
everyone thinks about them but like
someone told me that they send spies to
like local concerts to make sure that
people aren't making fun of them like
that's why Leah Remini like to share oh
she's always trying to expose them they
follow her to her hotel like they're
quietly like it's funny but they're also
dangerous and someone once told me
they're like people were like literally
tme me cautiously they're like don't
just like go looking at the Sea Org like
as a joke like people like go around try
and look like because you trespassed
they hold you on their property like
they lock you in there for hours and
then they let you go it's so crazy
so me and Margit which is like freaking
out I was like do I want to talk about
it do I don't even like one of those
prisoners that's like singing so
annoying that they would let me go thank
you
yeah totally I would just start jamming
out to shallow well I decided to talk
about it and it was really funny in the
show was great and then when we got back
up to my dressing room we were packing
up the stuff and I couldn't find my
planner now my planner is the book that
I carry with me everywhere it has all my
jokes written in it it has all my shows
in it my schedule my appointments just
like a lot of like it was a wonderful
thing for a person to have that jackie
told me there and it was really it's
like it's my life i bring with me
everywhere and i couldn't find it and it
was so weird it's like right before I
went onstage I was taking mirror pics
and I'm looking at the mirror pictures
I'm like a Margo look in the picture my
planner is right in front of me so I ran
to the mean green I'm like Margo just
find it and she's freaking out because
obviously we're thinking that they the
Scientologists know that I was making
fun of them and they stole my planner
and they're gonna follow me on tour cuz
all my appointments are there and
they're know where I'm gonna be and
they're gonna hide in the broom closet I
jump out in the deck and snap the wrist
and steal look exactly so I'm at the
main greed and Margo's freaking out I
guess she like FaceTime you she was
hearing noises she locked the door like
we were being so nuts and okay I ended
up just accidentally throwing into my
makeup case and we found it but that's
neither here nor there it's just the
fear that they'd instilled in me was
very real yeah I
it's honestly scary weekend because then
also we drove to Orlando and right when
I was gonna get him back for the mean
greet Margo was had the weirdest look on
her face I'm like what's wrong stuck
I'll tell you in the car I'm like okay
we get in the car and she goes I was
freaking out during the meeting I mean
I'm like why she goes this is the venue
that Christina Grimmie was shot at
during a meeting great and you know the
whole venue was giving me weird vibes
and there was policeman everywhere and I
was like this is weird like is Orlando a
dangerous city and we were also done
yeah from pulse so it was just honestly
I was freaking out like the whole
weekend it was giving me like like
chills honestly no offense but it's
Florida totally but Clearwater was like
such a cute town until the scientist
with all this at the road and it's like
so sad because we literally grew up in
Flour I love where I'm at like just as
much Floridian yes we lived in Florida
for like half the year yeah and now like
to see it so felonious far holy Wow a
year ago when we launched the podcast we
were number two in the podcast story we
like all the toasters were subscribing
leaving reviews before it even started
it was like so exciting they're climbing
the charts we're like let's head to
number one and we couldn't hit number
ones that a podcast called felonious
Florida had just launched as well just
launched as well and I guess because
there are so many felonies in Florida
like they just they co-opted so maybe
one year later let's try and get to
number one okay you can see you to do if
you have an iTunes I mean an iPhone
you're doing the podcast are you to
subscribe you should get anyone to
watcher just subscribe to our podcast it
won't ever bother you if you want to
leave a review make it five stars rate a
comment about how pretty we are that
people think just cuz you're number one
on the podcast or it's cuz you have the
most listens no that's actually quite
the opposite it's all about rates
subscribers and like and speed at trend
so it's like if we do this all at the
same time we'll shoot to number one like
a few hours and we just wanted to make a
screen Java yeah but we actually had
like a lot of reviews compared to other
podcasts but it's not it's all about
like it's all to happening now yeah yeah
so it's trending so if you're listening
to the podcast right now thank you for
listening and please feel free to leave
a review yeah we're just like business
we've been out here heading out our
business cards like trying to make a
living try to make a name for ourselves
and thank God I used this to print for
my business cards cuz I got 50% off he's
in Coto so I used vistaprint for my
thank-you cards oh did you a was able
them because I had like all
really great Lobos from our wedding and
it's like I won I was looking at
thank-you cards online they were so
[ __ ] cheesy I was like no I want like
the [ __ ] Erika Girardi Henry
condolence letter yeah that's what I
made that was like the why nerves and so
they'll be my thank-you cards and my
stationery for our family board and you
serve this to print code and you can too
okay so here it is miss Dupree wants you
to be able to own the now in any
situation which is why our listeners
will get 500 high-quality custom
business cards starting at $9.99 use
coded toast at Vistaprint calm that's
code TOA st at vistaprint.com
to get 500 business cards for $9.99
honestly I did that like five years ago
and I literally have never run out like
500 business cards is so much so much
you know yeah yeah okay next story
exciting Billboard Music Awards
performers announced ok Kelly Clarkson
Sam Smith's panic at the disco
we took my temps but firm enough oh no
Sam Smith I was think about Sam hunt
sorry Khalid normanni
and Lauren Diggle are also set to take
the stage during the Las Vegas ceremony
together
no like separately but I'd love Lord
dude I love Lauren Dale like really
crossing over from Christian music
carlins would be proud yeah host Kelly
Clarkson Sam Smith & Panic at the Disco
are among the performers set to take the
stage at the 2019 Billboard Music Awards
additional performers include Khalil
Oren Daigle normanni who will join Sam
Smith on stage okay Clarkson a five-time
BBA right they have a song together yeah
I haven't heard it the stranger I
haven't heard anything so behind on new
music so am i but like as someone who
travels a lot and it is in uber zai play
like that just play like z100 and
regular radio like there's like songs
come out and they never get played on
the radio this is everyone on iTunes
right so we were dancing with a stranger
which I know because I just love being
on Twitter like following people on its
rim I know no money and Sam Smith came
out with a song I have not heard one bar
it's really weird it I don't know I just
feel so out of touch and and I've really
anything when I'm listening to music in
an uber like I want to listen to my jams
I don't want I don't want to be trying
to get into what the kids are listening
to like I like post Malone as a person
but I don't know if I love like wow
right now I don't even know I love
sunflower do you know it no it's from
the spider-man movie it's actually one
of my favorite songs and that's why post
Malone it's just really crazy how like
radio they do a play
like blank space Billy Eilish no clue I
might as well be like no on this planet
if Billy
I think it's Elias know what Silas okay
if Billy Eilish came and slapped me in
the face
I would be like why is this homeless
girl slapping me in the face I have no
idea who she is she's so big she'll be
at Coachella maybe she'll slap you then
that would be awesome
yeah she was on Ellen like I don't even
know no and she's everywhere and it said
we just took a nap and we woke up and
Billy Eilish took over the world right
and then where did it start is she like
a tick talker no she's like I'm just
like an India okay you know no Shimo
she's a golfer
she's Indy I think she looks like she's
about to scream yeah very low community
it's kind of similar to like Maggie
Rogers really yeah that's her vibe she
would definitely gives me more like
Aerosmith bono where like everyone's
just like swaying and like a little yeah
that's all you should write a song okay
what's her song called shot lead vocals
what's her song called anyone no no
we're queen queen that's how it goes
yeah like
sounds really good okay I'm excited for
the more music more I loved Panic at the
Disco I just wanted to be out here
letting people know
don't forget about Panic at the Disco
know and panic at the disco like we
think that everyone's forgotten about
them but they're like on a full stadium
tour they're doing just fine no they're
fine like they have their loyal audience
but I feel like the mainstream like
hasn't accepted them since I walked in
we haven't you ever heard it's happy to
forget about them but then they give us
high hopes and we're like yeah playing
it on the radio all the time and we just
don't want to accept like we still like
Europe emo music you know it's so weird
how like bands like them and like Fall
Out Boy like we're so popular and then
every now and then they'll pop up with
like a banger like that Fall Out Boy's
that is key brand we did two men another
very ancient start with to mod that was
Chuck see the chod antidote to
everything except for me and then they
play Detroit senior fashion show like
ten years after their peak it's like
they have a lull Zemin panic at the
disco panic at the disco has high hopes
and then then they'll take a break and
then fall boy will come back maybe
second that serenade will make it
appearance
panic at the disco create a showman
right great still one of the greatest
gifts it's lovely not even make a wish I
wish you for happiness like this forever
oh I wish for an epic special and we're
just going more material items I'm a
Netflix special I mean the a partner for
the toast another great year full of
life love and the pursuit of happiness
and just survival at Coachella that's
really number one just like making it
through with all my limbs intact yeah
and like getting my powers yeah
obviously yeah like maybe getting in the
background like a paparazzi picture that
that's a good goal yeah should follow
around celebrities just we get in the
background of the pictures yeah the
people in the backgrounds like they
never fare well you know totally cuz
they focus them out yeah and they just
they never it never ends well you know
we have to we can't be in the background
we have to pretend like we're walking
with them you know like this group right
okay ah next story and something
unacceptable to even make a story but um
it was a lo story sort of day and I want
to talk about I mean they want us to
talk about this which is why I don't
want to understand but Stephanie Pratt
slams heidi-and-spencer quote I'm going
to expose then Stephanie Pratt is done
playing nice
just when fans thought the hills new
beginning star had made peace with
Spencer
Pratt the reality stars speaking out in
slamming her brother and heidi montag
quote no one knows the real heidi
stephanie shared on iHeartRadio sprat
cast episode from the River Terrace in
excuse me like I feel like I wouldn't I
get caught in someone else's sponsorship
like I'm annoyed told you know II mean
totally like I want to get that check
from the River Terrace in at not but
California totally cool before the hills
new beginnings my mom my brother and I
all sat down and we said we will not let
this ruin our family again
she added I'm done I don't care I'm not
protecting them anymore well honestly
that didn't really work out well for
them according to Stephanie she would
have an epic relation you know this this
time you know I'm saying but look it's
ruins right but or I think that surprise
for the yeah show because she doesn't
really say what they did but she said
I'm not gonna pretend it's Spencer and
Heidi are good people like I was doing
for this year for most of the series for
my parents for the expletive they have
done to me recently I'm done this is why
I moved to London I'm done they are the
most toxic people I've ever met they are
Bonnie and Clyde til they die so if they
say the sky is black all of us are
morons for saying it's so wait is she
done um there was a tweet saying
anything okay so there was a recap
someone in the toasters was like in
someone recap what Spencer uh Stephanie
Pratt said on the podcast and there she
went into detail gave me a second to
find it okay great because it was quite
salacious great hold on a sec she said
I'm done I'm done in confidence secured
enough of myself to not pussyfoot around
them I'm done I'm going expose them for
who they are Heidi doesn't want Spencer
to have a relationship with anyone but
her and you know what that's fine I
don't want a relationship with Spencer
anymore Gunnar I will miss the fact that
I'm going to miss out on the cutest
cutest cutest little boys early years
but it's not worth it okay ready at the
hills photo shoot last week Heidi was
being a [ __ ] to Stephanie and brought
champagne to the shoot and was giving it
to all the girls except for Stephanie
and Spencer wouldn't say anything to
Heidi so this was like the straw that
broke the camel's back and Stephanie
decided to spill all the tea that she's
been holding him for the sake of her
family which is as follows after the
hills by the way this is recap by Amanda
eller she deserves credit for writings
up after the hills wrapped Heidi and
Spencer flew to Costa Rica and cut off
all contact with Spencer's family until
they got arrested for possessing illegal
weapons and then they called Spencer's
dad who sent a private jet flew them to
Santa Barbara where they he put them up
in their beach house and they ended up
living for seven years
Stephanie wasn't allowed to put any of
this in her memoir that she apparently
wrote
dad Spencer I guess that's his family
has a lot of money while they were at
Santa Barbara's house why would they
were at the Santa Barbara house Heidi
remodeled the mom's closet took out one
of her bathtubs to build another closet
without telling or asking the parents
permission and put it all on Spencer's
dad's credit card when Heidi was
pregnant the parents put her and Spencer
up in a house in the Palisades and
financially supported them but now that
the baby's here Heidi won't let them see
him and his mom cries about it every day
- Spencer I mean - Stephanie Heidi is
manipulative and has been using
Spencer's family for money the whole
time apparently they're super loaded and
at one point Spencer was cut out of the
will because he was so horrible to them
and was so horrible to Stephanie that
she moved to London the parents
basically put up with it the dad doesn't
want to lose his only son again and the
mom is worried that the dad will blame
her and divorce her she Stephanie thinks
that Heidi planned to go up to San Fran
to meet LC the whole time and that she
was just planning to be famous never
liked LC and that Heidi did make up the
rumor that LC had a sex tape she
admitted that she's used a lot of her
family's money and that has put a lot of
strain on their relationship she says
the only thing she's really upset about
that she's likely gonna miss out on
Gunnar's childhood because of it she
says this is not just a storyline for
MTV and then she start a crime she also
said after the hills wrap the whole
villain persona really got to Spencer
and he got super paranoid and stockpiled
weapons and gained a lot of weight she
expect him she expects there will be
major fallout from this interview but
she said this needs to be done for
herself and she's taking a major step
back from her family
I know sadness this is the girl's
personal opinion I know stephanie has
been a little crazy in the past but she
sounded really lucid in common this
interview and I think I believe her oh
it seems a little extreme I think that
she actually is like really lucid and
and normal like she turned out really
well I don't know I met her and she was
like talking about Roxanne I'm like
please hear from the Palisades but me
too and hold on entities I love Spencer
- and having met him and people like
what you see on his Instagram persona
it's like he's crazy
whatever crystals but he's actually
quite like with it and when we met him
he was like super like career-oriented
and really normal so I don't know this
seems like I hate when people share
their journey family laundry like it's
so tacky
it is really tacky and also all of this
one you really think about when you put
it all together like yeah that's really
bad but if you take everything at face
value okay she moved to San Francisco to
become famous
she's not like the first or last person
to ever do that she had started a rumor
about LC sucks tape we all knew that
yeah like they denied it but that when
they were on the hills like they were
villainous villains and they enjoy being
villain so I don't think that they did
during that time was just fodder for the
show right and they were like that was a
crazy time for them that that's not who
they are now or who they pretend to be
now then when they went to Costa Rica
and disappeared
is that not when they were on I'm a
celebrity get me out of here ya know the
timeline doesn't really make a lot of
sense and I feel like if they got
arrested for illegal possession of
weapons we would know about it you know
I'm a so I want to see where that was
failed that was such a hilarious show oh
maybe that was filmed in Costa Rica
that's what I'm saying
so when you say um like they'd went to
go see her getting speared like they
were do we know what they were doing
right and this definitely feels like
thought like a storyline for the new
season because all the rumors around the
new season is that there's no footage
and it's so boring oh I mean there is no
footage they're still they just print
like gave a release heat and they're
still doing reshoots right like I think
it's so terrible um it says that it was
filmed in Australia oh that's not so bad
no but it's not Costa Rica so yes I
would need a more in-depth timeline if
I'm going to believe this seam or like
even like none of this stuff is like
truly shocking they lived in the house
for seven years like she want another
closet ready no that's not anything
crazy I've heard people do they live in
their parents house and remember when I
read a story about them I knew that they
were living in the parents house it's
you know I knew that the house that they
live at when Heidi was pregnant in the
Palisades was like owned or paid for by
their parents who cares like there's
definitely some like weirdness over
there but no one ever thought that there
wasn't no yeah and this isn't crazy it's
just I really hate when like okay you're
mad at your brother you think the best
bet is to do a podcast about him like
that's so stupid so like you're mad at
your brother the last time you guys did
a show together like you had to move to
London because it got so bad why would
you do with show again why would you do
a show again and it seems like your only
concern is getting to see gunner you
want you think you're ever gonna see him
again now that you're on a podcast
talking about how much money you're
gonna spend who cares it's weird and
Stephanie Pratt is weird because she has
a podcast with Derek Pass
no she is a podcast with Wells Adam
whatever and also what's weird
we talked about this last weekend and I
was thinking Matt anymore I was like
this is stupid she went on the date with
Derek path and then Toby got it on her
podcast and they talked about like if
they liked each other or not and it
didn't I was like if they had a good
time and it was like just go on like
[ __ ] date like that's if you're
single like that's why oh that's like
experimental date like stupid was really
weird it was like she went and reported
back to her podcast but it was like not
an anonymous person now on e you have
only been on one date that's so much
like weird pressure on the relationship
for the next you know it seems like
they're she's really just queuing up
this podcast to take over the world
because she keeps doing crazy [ __ ] on
podcasting people are talking about it
right and well I don't know one person
who ever listened to a podcast and will
inevitably talking about the hills but
even if this drama is real like it
wouldn't even be shown on the hills
though ya know and I read the actual
family [ __ ] doesn't get shown on TV
shows no like especially on the hills
where it is scripted yeah I can't I
still think it's like one of the worst
ideas that MTV has ever had me too and I
won't even watch it to talk about do you
think the best idea MTV ever had was um
but why they've had a lot buckwild I
would say that but someone died yeah but
not from the show no but maybe like you
never know know if he didn't do the [ __ ]
like there is that was definitely great
show and it's really sad that that guy
died for a million reasons but also cuz
the show didn't go on and he was the
heart and soul of the show and he's like
a really cute little cutie they've had
some really good shows no I mean Jersey
Shore Z Shore Jersey Shore now is like
whatever but that's heyday there was
nothing like Ana night Bob POW very
often go back and watch it and you'll
never be able to recreate reality TV
like that ever and people can try but it
was truly the greatest show truly and I
love are you the one still oh and also
next that was a [ __ ] hilarious show I
just was watching clips of it someone
put it in the Djoser's and it's like I
can't believe that show ever existed it
was like the most fucked-up show it was
so mean yeah oh my god that was a great
choice because it shows like necks that
we are where we are in the icy castle
culture totally things like that don't
happen again you know what I'm okay with
angry total okay fifth and final story
teens are spending $2,600 a year on
close here's where they'd like to shop
that's our average favorite brands of
teens okay it's not average annual
Siebert brands of teen survey teenagers
on average are spending twenty six
hundred dollars annually on food
favorite retailers for food or clothes
clothes and like just brands forever21
know is it retailers like stores or it
can be like online to both [ __ ] okay um
let me think what's the biggest retailer
in the world actually forever21 is all
their apparel okay
what about like PacSun well right now
I'm seeing Lululemon what Ulta Oh Alta
make sense
Amazon Oh duh vans what mm-hmm and then
American Eagle adidas forever 21
Hollister PacSun Urban Outfitters
Victoria's Secret H&M I hailey
Victoria's here like people still buy
stuff from that now I mean these are all
mom stories yeah what was the first one
again uh Lululemon
that is so weird even though Adam
Ygritte like a month ago some girl gave
me legging she's like I worked for Lou I
mean these are the best like it was in
the world and she was totally right
there they're the most amazing feel like
butter I've walked into a Lululemon but
I've really been considering it recently
no I wear like that SoulCycle Lululemon
for SoulCycle clothes cuz all my working
clothes are from so like oh but it's
like I'm paying so much more just so
there's no such as I don't go into a
Lululemon store
what are online I like to feel you know
I got to tell you the name of these
leggings they truly feel like new I have
a few lulu actually a while back
Lululemon send me some clothes and like
it was the greatest if it's a gift that
keeps on giving I wear it all the time
it's also the gift that keeps on giving
because those shopping bags last a
lifetime or sleepovers they're so ugly
they're so ugly but they're perfect like
in terms of their wear and tear and the
texture yeah I'm a big fan a big fan
soon it's always interesting to know
what the teens are doing yeah I wonder
if the teens are subscribing to cent
bird they should be they should be I've
been now except for some bourbon was one
of the first brands to on board for the
toast and it was one that probably have
used the most and really stuck with me
just because there's a smelly [ __ ] it's
always pertinent to have perfume with
you and especially travel-size perfume
so you could just throw in a purse you
know thing
so semper is a luxury fragrance
subscriptions
for perfumes and colognes wait for you
to discover new perfumes and colognes
without buying an entire bottle they
have more than 450 designer brands for
you to choose from Tom Ford Prada verse
ace Dolce & Gabbana you choose the
perfume you want to try and they send
you a 30-day supply
that's 120 sprays enough to apply more
than four times daily for a month if
you're not sure what type of site you're
looking for you can sort and find new
fragrances by brand style occasion sees
anymore
so with our exclusive offer just for our
listeners you can get 50% off your first
month of set bird that's only seven
dollars and fifty cents for your first
fragrance head to scent bird dot-com
slash toast use our code toast for 50%
off your first month that's scent bird
scen t-bird comm slash toast for you to
try your first perfume or cologne for
just seven dollars and fifty cents sign
on smell amazing
I [ __ ] love Stanford me too I
actually like a forty thousand in my
first at all time good okay so those
were our five stories Vanderpump rules
okay
it felt like a really long episode
because they were in Mexico and then
also stuff happened at home where I feel
like they usually end an episode like
leaving the place right you know and not
much happened in Mexico because they
didn't bring the villain didn't bring
the bill in and it was just like
honestly it was so stupid and boring
like the Doritos on the bed like I can't
honestly next week looks even stupider
and more boring it's it's really it's
it's losing its touch and that's so sad
of me because they're all getting along
and they refuse to film is characters
that they don't get along with um and
yeah so and I think they should film
with James cuz he really is interesting
but like I have no time or patience for
Billy or Raquel whatever Raquel comes
with James which I get but Billy is so
out of control and like on the way she
talks to Lisa is so crazy and all she
ever says is she reverts she took takes
up for people she's like fighting about
things that aren't even about her she's
fighting about James who gives a [ __ ]
and then she goes on to say why am I
responsible for James he's just my
co-worker and I love and respect him
he's just my co-worker but then she's
out here fighting every argument on
James behalf it makes no sense but you
and I invited places my co-worker that I
love I mean you're my co-worker that I
love but we're also sisters right no I
made C no sense she was being so
contradictory she was complaining about
not being invited to the engagement
party and she wasn't invited because of
her association with James so she's like
my so she met James he's not my son he's
just make over here I'm like oh you know
what she's right but then she's out here
on every our
even next week she's fighting about
James in on the couch with Tom and
Ariana it's make up your mind you want
to take up for James or not also an
engagement party is an intimate affair
and I've never seen her hang out with
Jackson Britney not only that that's the
thing the reason why she wasn't about it
has nothing to do with James they're not
friends you don't invite random straight
he didn't bring the point home because
she felt so long I was really sidelines
I uh I swiped blindsided yeah like that
conversation just came out of nowhere
and who was the rat [ __ ] Sheena
Sheena was really pissing me off
also when everyone everyone is obsessed
with Lala and definitely Sheena has like
a complex because all the girls were
mean to lava and Sheena was really the
only one who was never really that mean
to her and they were friends and then
Lala became friends with witches of WeHo
and now like JumpShip and hey Sheena but
when there was one malice so good - she
totally but when they were in the pool
and being cute and that's like oh wow
Katrina definitely feels like it's
secure no but she's now friends with all
the girls that and her and Lila have had
the same trajectory coming into the show
as not a real friend of the cast kind of
like the the town [ __ ] yep Sheena was
with Brandy's husband Bala was dating a
married man and eventually the witches
accept her but then she they never fully
accepted Sheena as she was when they
finally accepted Lila they loved
everything about her they didn't want to
change her they want it to be more like
her and scheana so and to hear about
that too jealous so when for the first
time ever someone had something negative
to say about Lala just said she was
being annoying about her anxiety what
she was and she passed Sheena pounds and
her argument was truly the thinnest
argument of all time I mean she wants me
to like hold her hand when she thinks
that even that she's like she'll make
out with Kristen honestly that that
sentence was everything you need to know
about Sheena it was honestly the worst
like saddest thing she could have ever
said like that's how you're upset about
all the girls get drunk and make out
with each other sometimes she and I
sometimes what's not like the fact that
she was drunk and the next morning still
thinking about that it is really sad
that's crazy I couldn't get over when
she said that my jaw literally hit the
farm like this is the saddest thing ever
no I literally was like why that's when
you're upset about and Lala was
definitely being away and like a little
drama queen with her anxiety but
everyone's that was the that was the
biggest charm of the trip brightly and
it was just like her like breathing on
dinner
and also they stayed at a hotel that
didn't have a beach that's pretty
other day the beaches are they're not
known for their beaches really okay yeah
it's like it was a weird hotel like in
the middle for the room it was really
pretty yeah it's more like a forest yeah
farsighted eyes were green yeah and
beachy yeah but didn't do it they
literally never left the hotel truly
actually the dinner on the last night
looked fun they were all just thinking
and having fun and then they like for
everyone's like let's get drinks and
like why it's the last night go home
yeah when Lila was laying in bed and
like they had to pack and go on a flight
like I had anxiety for her I was like I
was thinking to myself like oh my god
that's literally the worst position to
ever be in and I was like I never want
to be in that position ever checking to
where I don't know to be in with cameras
in your room with cameras in your room
when you're used to flying private and
you're flying commercial she does have
to stop with like the commercial private
they should be playing fine climate like
that wouldn't have been so terrible I
know none of us would have to do is get
her clothes in a bag and then like just
show it in well you have to go through
security you have to go through customs
sit at the lounge
Torche I felt so sorry for her yeah but
what she hungover hungover just exhaust
it's the moral hang over the physical
hangover yeah it's all of the downsides
of alcohol I don't there's too many
things that I don't like about Tom
Schwartz but I really don't like how he
talks about his like sex life with Katie
so much on TV and with other people like
it's not anyone's business like the
frequency in which you have sex is a
problem that you two have to figure out
on your own and I hate when he brings it
up I don't think he's always bringing it
up but I think just he's always like
making light of it because it's
obviously a weird thing between them yet
but still keep it between you there are
some things in a marriage that just are
nobody's business
no I agree I mean he gets away with it
cause it's him he gets with everything
yeah he get away with every also lisa is
a [ __ ] drama queen both of your chat
checks bounced no they didn't just one
right why did she admit that was the
whole thing coming up coming up like
when you weight over a year and at
Cashman's check I thought checks expires
in 90 days but we had this argument the
other day I think it's two years now
that that compliant it yeah so if you
find the check that's over two years old
you can check cash it but first of all
her waiting a year is weird shady why
well that was a whole other thing like
she because she was like holding it over
their heads and we haven't invested and
by the way and she knows that they have
the money they make especially Katie
who's been on the show in one episode
it's so stupid they totally have the
money and she
Sheila's just loves to like put them
down and she made the team like they
both got their checks pounds which only
one of them did and of course it did if
I were to check now who like things
change you change banks like house got
married they merged it's so [ __ ]
stupid
it's so stupid you got a new credit card
you want to go to a new bank with better
rewards yeah no it makes no sense Lisa
was being so every time handstand but
she did put Billy in her place and she
needed to and finally her being so mean
paid off cuz she was being mean in the
direction of someone who really needed
it yeah well I couldn't separate I
watched him he throws before minerals
and then I watched Game of Thrones after
Vanderpump rules and as I was going to
sleep and living in Westeros I was
trying to remember what happened I'm an
urban Broyles and I was and then I was
thinking of who's who okay and her phone
for us and I came up I think I gotta get
out of it Lisa is totally Cersei Lisa's
the Mad King oh but she's dead or she
Joffrey she's the Mad King no she's just
not everything lines up perfect because
this is Westeros Hollywood okay Stassi
and I know I know she loves Khaleesi
Stassi is Cersei and not in the negative
way I love her because first up she's
been the queen forever
there was one season where she had to
repent and came back crying shame Allah
chose for moving to new earth and
Patrick and that is Cersei when she's in
the Sept of Baelor and she's coming
through the streets to chance or covet
her don't she's back on top yep katie is
mark he's Margaery Tyrell okay why
because she had it a good good strong
start in the beginning at one point she
was queen yep not so much not anymore
but still relevant still relevant it
doesn't have nothing doesn't line up
perfectly you know it's just new
personalities Sheena I couldn't decide
wait let me think she's not gonna up she
nice Theon Greyjoy thousand per second
Joey because she's annoying she's always
wrong and I can't believe she's still
around totally that is a great great
point then after last night I was
thinking maybe she's Littlefinger cuz
she's always starting the pot the way
she ran from talking to Brittany totally
need to Billie but I do think when she
runs and tells people stuff like they
have her do that I don't think she's
that smart and manipulative up here
level she's a little finger is a genius
like mapping out Getty giclee Sheena
just does what people tell her
regardless of if it comes off manipulate
ever on yes Kristen let me take Kristin
I don't know if you're gonna get this
one what house well you'll get if I tell
you what happen Kristen is Santa in the
beginning annoying crazy and stupid and
now everything was her fault and now not
so bad okay okay that's really good okay
Ariana let me think Ariana I don't know
if this and Ariana started out as like
the villain
not really she's always been smart on
the ball and like people have liked her
and agreed with her point of view
Catelyn Stark Terry no terian because
she's like on because she's logical and
because she's so similar to Cersei sassy
which is why they don't like each other
telling the chap Tyrion is Jax no yes no
yes because everyone like you think
everyone thinks she's Jax he's driver
and anarion is like an evil enchanter
terrible things
terian never did anything bad all he was
was smart throughout you don't agree
with me no I'm thinking I'm thinking
thing it so who do you think Jax is I
didn't do the boys because I care about
them but I was actually thinking Jax was
King Joffrey
James is Ramsay Bolton and now
King Joffrey doesn't look so bad James
is 1,000% Ramsay Bolton and now Jax was
the first villain and compared to the
second one he doesn't look so bad no
because now I'm watching King Joffrey
and like he is bad just wait till you
got to Ramsay okay like what he does
like what he would have done with to
trip to prostitutes in his room right is
so much worse so much worse okay that's
an interesting and there was one more
okay there's two more so Lala Lala is
Daenerys yes he's the new queen and just
like Daenerys has her flying dragons
Lala has her body text totally told
she's the new guard huh then Oh Brittany
I love her she could have been anyone
but who's someone who's just always
right and really serves the betterment
of the realm
Lord Varys that's so good yeah totally
she's just like she's delivers messages
but not for any intent other than to
just cover he's here of heart Wow such a
great call such a great call we need to
write this down I wrote it because I was
singing last night then I woke up I was
like what were all my thoughts and I
figured it out in the HAR so I wrote it
- oh you know Jax is I don't think Jax
is king dropper because he was never
evil
but he was the villain Jamie because
Jamie's really likable but also villain
and did bad things okay but you think
he's like hot still and he still liked
it he started out with Cersei right okay
I think that's good I think that's good
too well I'm tired fun right okay so
other than that just you know one-year
commemoration yes their full show if
you're on the YouTube let's do a Q&A if
you have any questions just about the
show we did a patron episode a while
back about the ins and out to the show
we did a behind-the-scenes tour of our
studio we had a lot of questions about
like the business behind it the revenue
streams all that thing so if you're our
patreon patron you didn't get to see
that make sure to go catch up on it or
if you're wanna become a patron and you
need a reason to here it is check that
out but if you're on the YouTube stream
drop a question this is more so about
the spirit in the heart of the show yeah
just like what what we've learned in the
year what has been your favorite moment
of the the year of the toast the CMA red
carpet oh yeah it was so fun and I every
now and then we had a sizzle reel made
just cuz like it was so much good
content I'd go back and watch it and
there were so many moments that like
really made my life obviously like the
Kacey Musgraves of it obviously
obviously the kid from America I know
putting chocolates in his pocket like
there were so many iconic moments in
that stream like no matter where we go
in this world we have to always do the
CMA red carpet agree and I was just
pinching myself that we didn't do the
ACM red carpet which by the way I
watched they had a people now livestream
which I was really grateful for people
because they're never do TV like live
streams for country music and they had
Michael Rea which I thought was really
weird cuz he is like the number one song
on country he was talking to people like
who were technically like lesser than
him and he didn't stop talking about
Carly Pierce the whole time and the cute
but also annoying way and I had this
girl who was like in charge of moving
things along she was a true
correspondent and she knew nothing about
country music and it was so upsetting
like we should be doing that yeah we
need to somehow just get in contact with
people because they it was horrible okay
just wanted to put that out there well
but but then it's so funny because it's
like the CMAs were the highest high
followed by the lowest low the divine
diversion oh my god it's not about that
yeah well that's how it when it rains it
pours and then just you know the
universe just always keeps you grounded
but because you can't take off because
there's a snowstorm what was your
favorite part of the toast this year
oh the CMAs are great one
hmm I have to think like I hadn't
prepared for for these questions Oh
Margo as Christian or was a true hi oh
my god but I watch that's what I watch
all the time that makes me laugh I have
the Instagram video saved of all of her
weight so funny it was so funny that I
think that was one of my favorite moment
being citrus sisters naturally disagree
how have we managed disagreements I
think just knowing in the disagreement
like I think but in every disagreement
one of us is right and the other is
wrong I mean I am mostly wrong when it
comes to stuff and I usually just like I
I never fight like if I have an idea and
you or like you bounce back and you're
like I'm like oh she's totally right and
one out of like thirty times do I push
back thinking that I'm right but usually
I'm not but it's not even like ideas it
could be about guests or something but I
feel like either someone will feel
really strongly about we never both feel
so strongly about something yes if we're
disagreeing on something but you feel
way stronger then have it your way be
right I don't care so much great but
between us like usually one person feels
more strongly about it than the other
and that person can have their ways also
it's never really not big of a thing who
was a guest goal for season two well I
mean it used to be my dream guest was
Kelly Clarkson and honestly it still is
okay she would be an incredible guest
and I think she would bestow toasty and
just like get us on every level and we
would be friends for I agree it's a type
of thing where it's like she comes in as
a guest and leaves a friend yeah leaves
a sister but I think like as if I'm not
like looking for sisters necessarily as
a businesswoman like I think Kim
Kardashian coming on the show would do
wonders for the show we would fly to LA
for her of course we would I was like I
was a [ __ ] take a train
totally I love her so much what big
things are coming up for TMT in the next
year ooh we have some big things my
extensions are coming out in two weeks
that is big that's yeah yeah I mean we
have big things we did we're talking but
it's like I feel like ever and you know
what Justin Sylvester said this one I he
was unduly pop cuz I was like what's
next and I also hate that question me
too because that means what you're doing
now is not good it's too good that's
everything figured out and here let me
give you my game plan for war yeah like
the Lannister totally and he was like
I've said this before I want to die on
deli pop and it's like you know what if
I died I'm the toast not today but
eventually I'd 1:20 I like
I would love to die at home on a toast
in addition to doing other things buddy
for now and her always the toast is
enough and then we just it's about
building the community around it I
remember what we did our first show and
we said there's nowhere to go but up
because we had hit rock bottom
hmm but we also said like when people
are like where do you want to see the
show in a year when we did that patron
episode and we're like we're so excited
to see what the community like yeah it's
and like we didn't know it at the time
like that's camp toast you know like
those of us that are make that no other
podcast could do we are definitely gonna
franchise camp show so the next year
head to like Palm Springs yeah we have
to do like a West Coast cam Jost
um and it's like things like that that
makes this show really special and
different from other shows totally why
is this so different from all other
shows ha ha podcast ok what is the
number one thing you have learned about
each other from hosting slash working
together ooh I have learned wow that's a
tough question I learned that you never
stopped working like I am someone who
like when I get an email on my phone
like I don't open it until I got to a
computer like I'm very much like I am
either working now or I am playing but
you are always just like shooting off
emails working like making decisions and
it's like I I'm so I need to be coming
for that way but mostly it's because I
can't be on my phone in the car I just
hate like doing stuff for my phone ya
know and I also just get spurts of like
productivity where's like I'll go day
not doing anything in the next day I've
got everything done you know yeah but I
have learned from you is that you are
Raven Symone and you're psychic because
like well throw out an idea and Jackie
will just say why it's the worst idea
like how the outcome could be so
horrible I'm like holy [ __ ] you're right
and it's like I just think of everything
it's rainbows with fairy tales so great
and Jaksic well what if this happens I'm
like oh my god yeah that reason enough
is for us to never do it yeah truly
psychic doomsday if you could do one
thing differently when you started the
show what would it be
we're different fit get my chin done
earlier yes who is a guest and you
really anticipated and they just let you
down slash weren't up to the hype I feel
like we're particularly we don't take
guests just by the sake of having guests
no I have someone in mind that I will
never say whatever is
- and I know exactly why she was boring
but um it's it's yeah I wouldn't it
would have to be someone that I didn't
like that I want I'm not liking that I
would be happy to shame but I wouldn't
do that to one of our guessing you know
what coming on the show especially for
hosts like it's a lot not everyone can
do it no and we've seen like people who
you think are just like charismatic fun
and they come and they freeze in front
of the camera yeah and it's just like
you just think because they're bubbly on
the off-camera that it'll translate on
camera that's right on the Internet
yeah um hold on I'm looking well you do
what were the days immediately after the
shutdown of the breath like so you guys
immediately go into we're in it
rebranding Mon Brazeau every time you
didn't think you'd return to podcasting
we didn't go into rebranding mode for a
while we really took some time off and
just like yeah through our phones out
the window and just like relax
we always like knew that we would at
least start like do the podcast again
like Gia's never like should we or
should and we it was like this is what
we're gonna do when should we do it how
should we do it in a way that's
meaningful and people don't think we're
just like making light of this like how
how can we really move forward in a way
that's more meaningful and more positive
and take what we've learned but also not
be held down because of it right back
because of it and in so many ways like
that's exactly what happened like I
think the show is so much more positive
than the breath was oh my god since
their attitudes and I mean having this
happen to us like really puts so much of
what goes on with other celebrities and
like there
yeah those and their scandals and really
puts it into perspective and I think we
offer a unique perspective on a lot of
the canceled culture that's not always
popular hidden unwarranted yeah this is
a really interesting question it's not
always popular do you think you guys
will ever take the bow off the table
from Jackie's birthday um I would love
to know I think as long as this table is
here and in the way that it is I think
we should sooner clean the table he may
be a little Windex that wouldn't hurt um
would be too in LA weak for the toes of
course
yeah we're just gotta find some studios
baby it's to find some studio space it's
like the as much as you know it's just
like YouTube live it actually takes a
lot of equipment
yeah they don't work so it's not so
simple we could always do an LA podcast
right but are the attention being on are
the extensions just going to be in your
hair color no all shades 16 inches 8
inches it will be a robust collection of
Reds for redhead representation because
we've been maligned for so long but I'll
also have blondes brunettes something
for everyone and it's great hair quality
I'm not wearing them right now my hair's
grown like I wore them at my wedding and
I'm excited we're at Coachella oh my god
Coachella I can't well similar question
yeah well I think it's time I think it's
time let me grab my jackets gonna grab a
computer we are gonna take a knee
password off the merch store that means
our toast one-year anniversary merch
sale has officially begun all the best
sellers from the first merch drop to the
last merch shop will be there we also
have three new items two new sweatshirts
that are both really cute and the
champagne flute which you can get for
free if you order $50 or more but if you
just want the champagne flute you can
order it as a standalone item as well
and that's it report that the store is
live shot morning totes calm head on
over I need to buy merch I used to I
bought merch I mean be ever afraid but I
bought March I want I wanted to see what
it's like as a patron and honestly it
was premium as hell kept getting email
confirmations it shipped it arrived it
farted and I got it and I just wear all
of it honestly the don't worry B be
toasty shirt I just put that best most
comfortable shirt the the toaster should
actually be by my toes are certain size
large that is that's the best shirt the
comm team like supreme supreme yeah I I
put it in the laundry with a black towel
and it got ruined in now it's like rice
so that was my mistake
yeah the sorority sweater is we actually
very interestingly enough to sold so
many sorority sweaters at the vendor in
which we use sold out of them completely
like we the warehouse we dropped we what
sort we dried out the warehouse because
that's how many sorority sweatshirts
robots so unfortunately they're not in
this drop we'll try and get them again
in a few months but it's also summer so
we have a lighter weight pullover with a
hood that's like very low-key the
materials more like a terry cloth yeah
like don't hold me to that read the
description but it's like low-key
usually the toast logo it was like so
big but this is just champagne and
clinking glasses and then when you pull
up the hood it says morning toast on the
back and I've been seeing actually
people wearing the merch to meet and
greets and shows and it's so interesting
at people's style them the Old English
black shirt is probably the most popular
I love that shirt they tuck it into
high-waisted jeans and they look so cute
yeah people really style it very
interesting people also wear that and
the
Ardi sweatshirts oversized with like
ariana grande boots love that nice that
smooth and the pop sockets are back
obviously the pop socket is every time
I'm doing a meeting every picture I look
at the phone of the person taking it and
they always have a pop socket which I
love and it's also a good way to spot a
toaster in the wild so if you get the
regular pop socket you can spot a
toaster in the wild or if you got a
toaster in the wild pop socket you could
spot I trust her in wild yeah that's
like it's like a bad signal for just
fellow people who you should be hanging
out with
yeah so reminder that if you spend $50
or more you get the free champagne flute
with our logo on it but if you just want
the champagne flute you can buy it as
well I feel like I'm on QVC and I feel
like I'm actually doing a roll you want
anything else I have a full card I'm
getting the champagne is it on yours on
business
it's on me my treat could I say CY but
what's for sale you we you know what's
for sale you know I forgot though okay
I'll take a sweatshirt oh it's a little
pricey okay what color pig what sighs
hmm I kind of want it to be big large
extra large yeah I actually got a small
so I sure because I've been thinking
like itted when I worked out well that
sounds miserable working out and wearing
a fitted sweatshirt I don't know what's
worse I actually do need another pop
socket what color I'll take black now
which one oh I'll just put her in the
wild so much variety a totally Oh cute
okay
I also just love Shopify it's like such
a premium experience shop morning toys
calm shot morning toast calm it's
available for 24 hours unlimited stock
it'll take two weeks to ship because
it's all pre-order so we can make sure
everyone gets what they want so don't be
surprised
be sending customer service emails but
it's like it's been a week it's not here
cuz it takes two weeks it says it on
every item description page and before
you check out two weeks and we are going
to do another merch drop it a little bit
for camp toast merch yes got really cute
stuff something for this gun yeah stuff
fur camp if you're coming we're also
gonna be selling merch at camp so don't
feel like you have to buy everything
upfront but if you can't make it and you
want to feel a part of the camp toast
vibe you can buy camp toast anyway if
you want to ensure that you get your
sizing properly like get it before camp
yeah so that's all we got for you make
sure to head to shop morning to us calm
also we're trying to complete our goal
of becoming number one on iTunes so make
sure to leave this podcast a five star
review subscribe to it listen to it
share it tweet it the whole thing and
that's it thank you guys for being so
wonderful and amazing year making this
enemies
and to another amazing year a toast to
the toast a toast to our real friends
they don't care about that he said she
said and I'll leave you with that yes
shot morning toast calm love you guys so
much we're back tomorrow with Blake
portsmen and then on Thursday with an
around a singer so it's just a fun
packed week thank you guys for being
here the morning trust the Malena a
morning show we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so make sure to subscribe and
give this video a thumbs up and we're
also available as a podcast on iTunes
Spotify and anywhere you can listen to
podcast so bye
you